ist unser universum etwa gar nicht
allein sondern das spiegelbild eines
anti universums genau davon ist ein
kanadisches forschungsteam überzeugt
demnach ist das universum mit einem
gegenpart aus antimaterie auf der
anderen seite des urknalls verbunden
doch nicht nur dass dieses anti
universum könnte tatsächlich die lang
ersehnte erklärung für die mysteriöse
dunkle materie liefern kriegst um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen
vielen dank für euren themenvorschlag
aus der telegate community das ist echt
ein super spannendes thema der gängigen
lehrmeinung zufolge fing alles vor etwa
13,8 milliarden jahren an denn mit dem
urknall soll damals materie und
antimaterie zeit und raum und das
universum entstanden sein
doch warum gibt es viel mehr materie als
antimaterie
das ist tatsächlich eine physikalische
ungereimtheit die forschungsteams
weltweit den schlaf raubt und so kommen
die beiden physiker me to rock und lemgo
aus kanada auf eine super spektakuläre
theorie
demnach ist unser universum nämlich
nicht allein laut ihrer studie könnte
sich stattdessen bei unserem universum
um das spiegelbild eines universums aus
antimaterie handeln letzteres könnte
sich ebenfalls beim urknall gebildet und
sich dann aber entgegengesetzt
ausgedehnt haben
dieses anti universum könnte dem
kanadischen forschungsteam zufolge mit
unserem universum verbunden sein und
quasi eine spiegelverkehrte gegenseite
zu unserem universum beben in ihrem
modell gegen die beiden physiker davon
aus dass im anti universum die zeit in
die entgegengesetzte richtung läuft und
mehr antimaterie vorhanden ist als
materie hier gebe es keine partikel wie
in unserem sichtbaren universum sondern
anti partikel auch die raum
eigenschaften wären komplett umgekehrt
zu denen unseres universums mit diesem
modell wollen die beiden physiker aus
kanada alle bislang beobachteten
phänomene mit hilfe von teilchen und
feldern erklären die uns bekannt sind
das ganze gedankenexperiment von to rock
und basiert darauf dass das universum
der sogenannten cpt symmetrie
unterworfen ist ein gebilde das diesen
fundamentalen gesetze der physik
unterliegt müsste aus
ein paar bestehen aus dem universum und
einem anti universum nämlich so könnte
dann auch das mysteriöse ungleichgewicht
in unserem sichtbaren universum erklärt
werden also warum mehr materie als
antimaterie vorhanden ist warum die zeit
vorwärts läuft und warum sich das all
aufbläht die beiden forscher kritisieren
dass gängigen kosmologische modell das
die entstehung des universums beschreibt
demnach entstanden energie zeit und
masse bei der expansion die man als
urknall bezeichnet hierbei wurden sterne
planeten atome und subatomare teilchen
gebildet obwohl on to rock sehen das mit
skepsis denn ihrer meinung nach verlässt
sich dieses modell zu sehr auf
sogenannte ad hoc parameters gemeint ist
damit beispielsweise der parameter den
mann als inflation bezeichnet und der
vereinfacht gesagt die schnelle
expansion des universums erklärt
entscheidend ist aber dass diese ad-hoc
parameter genau wie weitere andere auch
eben nur für diesen einen zweck
entwickelt worden ist nämlich um das
standardmodell zu erklären alternativ
schlägt das forschungsteam ein anderes
modell für die entstehung des universums
vor demnach könnte es sich nicht
exponentiell oder explosiv entfaltet
haben stattdessen haben sich raum und
zeit vielleicht kontinuierlich im anti
universum und universum ausgedehnt die
beiden physiker geben auf der anderen
seite aber auch zu dass ihm bislang noch
die beweise für ihre eigene theorie
fehlen doktorat umbau geben sich
zuversichtlich diese aufzuspüren und
somit auch langfristig die mysteriöse
dunkle materie ein für allemal zu
erklären denn ein solches universum das
mit einem anti universum verbunden ist
würde eine große anzahl an neutrinos
schaffen und diese teilchen gelten als
mögliche kandidaten für dunkle materie
wann betritt der erste deutsche den mond
das ist eine ganz andere frage und die
beantwortet jakob von breaking lab
anklicken also hier anschauen und
breaking lab auf jeden fall abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran